Pope Francis says the Catholic Church is
under attack by the devil at a gathering
of Bishops over the weekend there are
investigations into sexual abuse by
clergy in 13 different states including
the Diocese of Buffalo New York 60
Minutes spoke with members of Buffalo's
Catholic community they are revealing
the scope of the efforts to cover for
accused priests one of them was Father
Fabian marianski
his file included an accusation that
during the 1980s he had sexual relations
with a girl that began when she was just
15 the diocese knew about it but a note
in the file argued marianski should be
excluded from the list of problem
priests it said we did not remove him
from ministry despite full knowledge of
the case and so including him on list
might require explanation and I remember
thinking if that's the rationale for
leave me a priest off then how can I
abide by this she was not alone Father
Bob's iliacs advised the bishop on
Church law including abuse cases he told
us he was disgusted by how the cases he
saw were handled
I think the Apocrypha of the lip service
you know the yes Bob I agree with you
and then I would walk out of an office
and nothing would happen
Buffalo's Bishop Richard Malone declined
to be interviewed he did release a
statement saying in part the church is
in the eye of a storm largely as a
result of wrong decisions made decades
ago but our efforts have always remained
steadfast protect the children and
reconcile with the victims
siobhan o'connor is a whistleblower who
leaked hundreds of pages of documents
detailing those cover cover-ups Paul
Schneider is a church deacon and the
first clergy member to call on bishop
Malone to resign they both join us at
the table good morning to you both
morning John I should say Paul said in
the green room people use the word hero
but you really he says or a true hero it
is not used lightly when it comes to you
I wonder if you could take us through
your process on how you decided that you
were going to leak the documents to the
press you had how you felt about Bishop
Malone and how you reach the conclusion
that you did
well I worked for him for three years
and I really enjoyed working with him I
cared very deeply about him
I planned my whole life around his
schedule I didn't take vacations unless
it worked for his schedule so it was
very painful for me to realize that what
the how the diocese was handling this
issue didn't match what people thought
what were you seeing where I was seeing
that there were cases I had grave
concerns about and even back in March
early on I would express those concerns
and he would just try to placate me in
response what had he saying
well he would say that that's not your
concern he would say this is being
handled he would say don't worry about
it
but I couldn't help it because for me
the heroes and the story are the
survivors and I spoke to so many of them
and I so desperately wanted to help them
and it was when I realized the power of
the media actually and the journalist
Charlie with whom I worked I saw that
when he would email about something
all of a sudden action would be taken
and that's when I realized that I might
need to do that I would never have
wanted to and it was very painful but I
saw that it was necessary in this way
speaking to the press was incredibly
helpful
because it helped expose what the church
was unwilling to address itself Paul
when you became the first Deacon to call
for the bishops resignation did you hear
from other people I did I heard two
things first that clergy were afraid to
speak out they were afraid of
retribution by the bishop they didn't
know siobhan was the whistleblower but
they and I thought she had brass and
felt she had the kind of courage that we
should follow but we're living in a time
in Buffalo where the type of activities
that have taken place we thought only
occurred 70 years ago 40 years ago these
abuses have happened now and for a
person such as Siobhan to have the
courage to come forward to help our
church find truth everybody should be
supporting her and anyone who doesn't
must not be seeking the truth you can
why is our church having such trouble
finding the truth silence secrecy we
have had a culture of this throughout
the Catholic Church for ages too much
power and too few men and those are the
bishops they need to be held accountable
why is bishop malone still on the job
today
do you think because Gil he answers to
an audience of one that person is the
Pope
good or bad however you feel about the
Pope only he can remove this bishop what
we are praying for what I've asked for
and what so many others are asking for
is for bishops around the United States
who have said no more no tolerance than
act on those words and make this bishop
leave this post Siobhan you said the
diocese is named 42 accused priests and
say they were released a list of more
you say there are how many priests in
total that there would be over 100
if the list was accurate mm-hmm having
seen their draft lists and knowing how
they crafted these criteria that
resulted in a much smaller number and
yet I would speak to survivors who said
why is it my abusers name so they have
you talked to Bishop Malone has he
reached out to you to say how could you
why did you he has not I have not spoken
to him for several months and while I
know that that might be a painful
conversation I I would I would not
prevent it because I would like to speak
to him he he matters to me and I
struggle with that still but I hope he
would recognize that I had to do this
for the survivors for the diocese I love
and for the church I love I want that I
want not only to be a whistleblower but
to be part of the reform and the renewal
the church needs me I'm so overwhelmed
by your moral Kirti courage and clarity
I really am thank you thank you thank
you very much both of you thank you
Siobhan O'Connor's her name and Paul
Snyder